MARK MANDEL: Hi and
welcome to Managing
Multiplayer Game Servers.
My name is Mark Mandel, and
I'm a developer advocate
for Google Cloud for games.
Today I want to talk about
large-scale, multiplayer,
online games and how Google
Cloud's products can support
these types of workloads
for a player base
that spans the world.
At the foundational
level, we have
Kubernetes and Google
Kubernetes Engine, or GKE.
The combination of having
both a managed platform of GKE
as well as the open-source
nature of Kubernetes
means that we can place our
game infrastructure anywhere
in the world that
players show up,
ensuring a low-latency,
real-time experience
for everyone.
But Kubernetes is
just the beginning.
Another open source
project you may
be familiar with from
Google Cloud is Agones.
Agones is designed as
a batteries-included,
open-source, dedicated game
server hosting and scaling
project built on
top of Kubernetes,
with the flexibility
you need to tailor it
to the needs of your
multiplayer game.
Since going 1.0
in September 2019,
Agones continues to grow its
suite of tools specifically
tailored to running
multiplayer game servers on top
of Kubernetes cluster.
The relatively new
offering in this suite
of multiplayer
game hosting tools
is Google Cloud Game Servers,
which is in public beta
right now.
Agones is a fantastic
project that
excels at writing
dedicated game servers
within a single
Kubernetes cluster.
Cloud Game Servers
is a management layer
that sits on top
of Agones to power
your global, multi-clustered
game server workloads.
It provides you with the ability
to connect Kubernetes clusters
from Google Cloud as well
as hybrid and multi-cloud,
not locking you into a
single cloud provider.
It also gives you a high degree
of flexibility and control
since you still have access
to your underlying Kubernetes
clusters.
On top of that,
powerful features
provide visibility
and simplicity
in running, scaling, and
orchestrating your game servers
for your global player base.
Cloud Game Servers has
several concepts at its core.
First, a Game Server
cluster, which
is a Kubernetes
cluster that has Agones
installed and is registered
with Cloud Game Servers.
Secondly, you also need a way
to logically group together
your Game Server
clusters in a way
that makes sense for the latency
requirements for your game.
We call this concept realms.
And it gives you the
ability to group clusters
as you see fit for
retrieving ready Game
Servers from across a realm
via multi-cluster game server
allocation.
It can also be used
as a target for all
or some of your Game Server
fleet deployments and updates.
Finally, we have Game Server
configurations and deployments.
These are Agones-based
configurations
that are able to be
deployed across some or all
of your clusters
around the globe,
defining both your fleets
of ready Game Servers
as well as autoscaling
capabilities.
For example, if we had
a project called Game X,
we could split it across
three separate realms,
such as US, Europe, and Japan.
Within each realm, we can have
a series of Game Server clusters
hosted on Google Cloud, On-prem,
or potentially other clouds
as well.
Finally, we would
roll out our fleets
of ready Game Servers
across our realms
using Game Server deployments
and configurations.
Getting started with
Cloud Game Servers
is relatively straightforward.
First, install Agones on
your Kubernetes clusters
and register them with
Google Cloud Game Servers.
Second, decide on how you want
to organize your Game Server
clusters into realms.
Finally, write and roll out
your Game Server configurations
and deployments
to host and scale
your Game Servers across
all your Agones clusters
around the world.
Let me show you a quick
demo of how easy it
is to roll out Game
Server fleets across four
different Kubernetes clusters.
As you can see
here, I previously
set up four Game
Server clusters,
split between two realms--
Europe and the United States.
To roll out my global
fleet, I'm first
going to create my
deployment and name
it stk for the awesome
open-source game Super Tax Cut
that we're going to deploy.
Next, we will create
a configuration
for this deployment,
and we'll call it v1.
If we have a look at the
config I pasted here,
we can see our configuration for
our Cloud Game Servers fleet.
We'll create two replicas of
our Super Tax Cut game server.
This may look familiar if
you've used Agones before.
We could also create our
autoscaling rules at this point
if we so desired.
The config and deployment
have been created,
but it has not yet been rolled
out to all our clusters.
So let's do that.
I click Manage Rollout
and then select
the config I want to roll out
to all my clusters and hit Save.
Let's now look at
one of the clusters
we've already connected to.
And we can see our
Game Server fleet has
been spread across the clusters,
and they're ready to go.
To recap, we saw that
we had a previously
configured, global,
multi-cluster, Agones
deployment, which was already
organized into two realms.
From there, we were able to use
the power of Google Cloud Game
Servers to roll out
our dedicated game
servers across our
global infrastructure.
This is just the tip of
the iceberg of features
for Google Cloud Game Servers.
There is much more to explore--
including multi-cluster
allocation, aggregated metrics,
and more.
If you're interested
in getting started
with any of these projects,
including Google Cloud Game
Servers, the URLs to do so
are on the screen right now.
[MUSIC PLAYING]